if you feel that down by the EU  institutions the person to turn to is  the Ombudsman the present one stands  down in October and the hunt is on for  his replacement six candidates appeared  before the petitions committee to  explain why they should have that job  and what they do first was the current  Ombudsman for the Netherlands Alex  brennick mayor next came Marcus Jaeger  illegal specialist from the Council of  Europe the morning session was rounded  off with mep rear omen writin of the EPP  the afternoon session brought Ireland's  Ombudsman Emily O'Reilly before the  committee she was followed by two more  MEP candidates firstly Dagmar at verint  of the Socialists and finally Francesco  Speroni of the efd group the petitions  committee will now assess how each  candidate performed and the final  decision will be taken during the July  prina recession